hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video i would
like to ask a question a question that
might seem at first sight a little bit
disturbing but that is actually very
legitimate and that to me makes a lot of
sense so my question is is amc the new
safe heaven and to answer that question
i'm gonna compare amc to the usual safe
heaven that we know which are gold usd
gpy and the dollar let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so my question is is amc a
safe haven
so first let me do a little bit of tier
very quickly on amc because i know that
you guys are here for that so
nothing very new so once again on the
long term
one two three four five one four we're
expecting a fixed wave and in this fifth
wave we might be doing a one two and
waiting for a third wave uh it looks
like the third the second wave is
complete because we broke this trend
line guys we broke it here with a
massive move up on the mc that was
negatively correlating with the spy and
i'm going to show you guys very quickly
something that i think is very
interesting and i'm going to answer with
some macroeconomical uh
arguments
this question so first let's uh here we
can see that we have this breakout we
are now sliding on the yellow trend line
all right see if it's the third day in a
row that is uh not bullish
i mean we closed a bit higher yesterday
but it's not very bullish it's not what
we expect after this kind of breakout
but it's not looking too bad because we
are still above this yellow trend line
so what i expect here guys once again is
something like this here we know we have
a lot of gamma i'm going to show you
that here again but what is very
interesting in this video guys and
you're gonna see is
let's have a look at so you should you
saw already guys that when i go on an
hourly timeframe this strong move up
on amc was actually triggered by some i
think margin calls that is coming from a
move down that we had on the spy so it
was here guys
bam bam bam so sorry which day it was it
was
30th of september 29 and 9 pm so 30th of
september sorry so this one all right i
get it so this strong move down here
whenever we basically broke this trend
line
here bam it triggered some strong moves
up on amc so let's have a look at how
the other assets where people usually go
to when they feel in danger where they
feel that that the markets might crash
so they want to go into something that
will not go down something that is
strong and resilient to crisis so they
usually go to gold so let's check on the
30th of september how gold has reacted
so i'm here on the gold chart the hourly
chart and we can see that on the 30th of
september guys here the gold rushed
there was a rush for gold and it went
just higher we did we have the breakout
i mean yeah we have a breakout we can
have a breakout here we went higher and
we are staying high so people got scared
people bought gold fair enough it has
always been like this we fully
understand the reason behind this kind
of of investments is because gold is a
real safe haven because it is a value
storage that is physical so people like
it another safe haven is the
jpy currency so the usgdpy should
actually go lower when the market
crashes so let's check what happened on
the 30th of september at 9 pm and guys
it was here right and you can see the
usd jpy was going lower so people were
buying yen the japanese yen basically
and i've i've been working you know on
asian markets for quite some time and
i've always heard that you know that the
jpy is a safe haven
and you know
we made fun of that at work because it
you know when things turn bad why would
you go for jpy you know it's it's a
question i have always had
and when you just type usd jpy 7 on
google you're gonna see the yen is also
a safe haven simply because that is what
market participants consider it to be
investors shift towards jpy during
turbulent times as that is what market
habits and traditions have taught them
to do okay so this is kind of a joke i
mean you know there is no real
explanation but if you think twice about
it
actually there is an explanation you
know the
japan have a very high level of debt
around 250 percent
so they basically owe money but they owe
money to whom who is actually holding
the japanese debt it's japanese people
it's a domestic debt all right this is
something that we know
and somehow i think that this is the
reason why the yen is a safe haven is
because we know that it's not foreign
investors that have yen and that
certainly could sell it it's japanese
people that have their own currency that
hold their own debt and they're not
gonna sell it i mean you know because
they live in japan it's domestic
and i think that this is how a safe
haven
is initially built is whenever people
who hold
most of the assets that we are
considering are people who we know
believe in this asset and are not going
to drop it if things turn bad like
japanese people with their own currency
you know they're not going to sell the
yen because they needed to to leave
right
and
it's funny to see that this correlation
when you look at amc guys we had the
same moves that we had on gold than we
had on the yen and here i think and it
was much sharper because i think it was
a margin call but the truth is that i
think it can be more than that if
markets keep you know just dropping and
my technical analysis on the spy is not
great yet it's better but it's not great
you can see guys i'm bearish on the sp
why since we have this breakout on the
15th of september roughly 20th of
september it was dropping since the 1st
of september
then we had this breakout we tested it
we moved lower and i'm gonna keep my
bearish stance uh as long as we are
below
this trend line all right guys so this
trend line that is here in blue
so roughly right now the level is at
440. so as long as the spy is below 440
we are bearish okay so if we are bearish
we might see this is the line i drew
some days or weeks ago for now it's
following this line i think we're gonna
go lower uh within next week or maybe
two weeks i don't know and that
basically we're gonna be bearish for one
month you know something like this with
maybe a low around 400 that's my view
let's find out what's happened what
happens here but i'm pretty sure that
people will keep rushing to those safe
havens if there is fear on the market
and once again i think that it might not
only be margin calls
that you know triggered those strong
moves up but really the thought of
people who hold amc
who are like for 80 percent or even
maybe 90 percent uh apes you know and
knowing that those people they will not
sell amc even if things turn bad because
you know they believe in it so strongly
they believe in the squeeze
that i think
other investors would actually put their
money in the safe assets which is a bit
ironical because there are a lot of
analysts that say that amc is overvalued
but even being overvalued people won't
close their positions they will keep it
for a very long time not depending at
all about what the rest of the market is
doing
and i think that this is
the definition of a safe haven and if
this analysis starts to really
go through the big money players mind
i'm pretty sure they would agree with me
i've discussed that already with some
friends they were making a bit fun of me
but in the end they agreed and they they
think that it makes sense so let's see
what's going to happen but my tian on
amc is positive my tier on spy is
negative uh we've spotted this negative
correction at play once then it was not
happening again we had a strong uh
bearish day
on monday and amc was done as well so
it's not all the time happening so there
is still some mechanisms i fully don't
understand but definitely something is
there and if people understand that amc
is a safe heaven it will make this
statement even more true very quickly
let's have a look at the synthetic short
interest roughly the same so six percent
of synthetic shorts 19 of regular shots
so 25 of total short a lot of upside
gamma around the collocated mostly
around the 40 50 and 60 strikes guys so
this is where we're gonna have this
strong moves up coming again if amc
trades around those levels so that's why
technicals here help me to kind of guess
we're gonna start moving higher we need
a spark we need something to start this
move and then the gamma is gonna do the
rest and maybe even uh the investors
that rush to amc to make a safe
investment and very quickly guys for
those who are wondering what is this new
painting in my bookshelf it is actually
not a painting it is a photograph that
has been created by a friend of mine
she's living in hong kong for a while
she's an artist she's doing photographs
and editing it
about the city about the culture here
she's doing an impressive and amazing
work guys so just click on the link in
the description of this video i really
wanted to help her to promote her work
because she's a very good person guys
and there is nothing here to buy it is
just for you to see and watch and i'm
doing this for her because once again uh
i think it's important for people to
support each other so just go and have a
look guys so that's it for me i hope you
guys enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show see you guys